If you don't fix wealth inequality then we have
to have high taxes on the middle classand
bad education, bad healthcare, bad welfarestate
you know you get the worst of all possibleworlds
The reason i think that wealth inequality is
the most important thing in the economy is um
basically because all the other problems
housing, lack of good jobs, lack of good wages
government debts, government deficits, not enough
money for good quality education, health care
these are basically all being caused by
problems with wealth equality and i didn't
i didn't really go into work in the city with the
idea that i was gonna, as an inequality campaigner
basically i wasn't a campaigner i just wanted to
i wanted to be able to forecast well & to make money
and um it needs to be understood that markets and
economists are continually forecasting incorrectly
um so they're missing something that's very
important there's something very important
that they don't understand and uh things continually
fail to improve because they're missing something
and having studied economics at university
and then gone on to work in the city
i can see that these guys don't
understand the significance of inequality
and because of that they've been constantly
struggling to understand why there's not
enough spending and demand in the economy and um
once you understand that the problem is spending
and you also understand that most ordinary
people are basically most ordinary people
they spend everything they make in their lives
right the vast the vast majority of people die
with nothing left they spend everything and
yet we've got a problem of not enough spending um
so for years i sort of struggled to understand how
can we get this spending and um it basicallyif
if governments are governments are already
overextending they're borrowing to spend
ordinary people are borrowing to spend, the only
people who caninject that demand into the economy
is the rich basically
but i think all of the other politicaldemands
that people want - more affordable housing
better jobs, a stronger economy in a variety of
ways they simply are not affordable unless you
fix inequality specifically wealth inequality um
but if you do fix wealth inequality basically
anything becomes affordable so it drives me mad
that economists don't talk about inequality more
but i guess i should be grateful that they
don't because that's why i've been able to
make so much money because their predictions
are always wrong and mine are always right but
we simply cannot build a better society
without the wealth of the super rich
and if we don't do anything then not only will we
not access their wealth but they will continue to
progressively take more and more of our wealth
so really i'm not saying it's the only thing
that matters in the world of course it's not but
in terms of the economy basically nothing else is
possible unless we fix wealth inequality so it's
the it's the cornerstone it's the foundation stone
we need to fix wealth inequality and then allthe
other questions we can ask and we cananswer
do you want a big welfare state? okay well
you can have one if you fix wealth inequality if
you don't then you can't have one, okay well do you
want low taxes? well you can have them if you fix
wealth inequality, well if you don't then you can't
have them, if you don't fix wealth inequality then
we have to have high taxes on the middle class&
bad education, bad healthcare, bad welfarestate
you know you get the worst of all possibleworlds
whereas if you fix wealth inequality then you know
like we could build, we could have that15 hour
week if we wanted to or we could have
100 hour week and we could be phenomenally rich
you know what i mean but if you don't fix wealth
inequality then the direction of travel isdownwards
basically and that doesn't thatdoesn't end
there's nothing within the system thatautomatically
fixes that so you know i believe that capitalism
can be a great system and it canprovide
great human outcomes but if you don't fix
wealth inequality we will get bad outcomes for the
vast majority of people, so it's not a question of
do i think it's the most important thing i think
nothing else is possible if you don't fix it
so um yeah we need to get people people
behind it and um it's important to understand
that the economists don't realize that
most economists don't realize that
but it's also important to understand that most
economists come from wealthy families and
they own property so they're not being hurt
by it and they're well paid so unfortunately
it falls upon ordinary people who are the people
getting hurt to come out and fight for it
um and people need to come out and fight for it
people need to come out and say we're not gonna
we need to start demanding explicitly from
governments - measure wealth inequality and
make sure it's decreasing - because it's increasing and
as much as that happens then less and less will be
politically and economically possible
in terms of getting society more...
housing could be so much more affordable wages
could be so much higher and we could have so
many more options in how we live our lives some
of them put a lot of money into paying economists
and think tanks to tell you that inequality
is important for the economy that is not true